[Music]
Tuesday's America's Got Talent was truly
must-see TV as one contestant
accidentally hit the golden buzzer for
himself and another walked offstage
after an awkward moment with Simon
Cowell you are getting on my nerves
right now even me it's done this a long
time even I get surprised so a hilarious
turn of events showed contestant Ben
trigger taking the power of the buzzer
into his own hands
[Applause]
both confetti exploded but it didn't
count
lucky for Ben he got four yeses from the
judges taking him to the next round I
just feel so grateful that now we get a
chance to be here and be a part of I
don't know just making making dreams a
reality for these contestants I love
being a part of making dreams come true
it's nice to be a part of saying yes to
someone's dreams but the night wasn't
all fun and games here's what happened
when singer Lamont Landers took the
stage that's a very safe what I would
call wedding song Simon suggested Lamont
leave and come back later to sing a
different song
but Lamont took it to the audience I
think you should come back later because
right now we're not understanding each
other what what do you guys want and
that left Simon feeling pretty annoyed
you are getting on my nerves right now
because I actually like your voice and
I'm gonna give you another shot don't be
cocky Lamont eventually took Simon's
advice and walked offstage to go learn a
new song later when he returned it was a
completely different vibe
[Music]
that performance got lamont four yeses
and he even thanked the judges for their
tough love I'm humbled and I'm honored
that you know you guys took the time to
give me another chance
[Applause]